you have uh under shenzhen uh who's
going to from the university of
pennsylvania department of statistics
and he's going to tell us about
uncertainty qualification and the
predator release model uh take advantage
[Music]
thank you frankie for introduction and i
thank the organizers and xiaomi pauline
and lauren for the invitation it's my
great pleasure to be here and in today's
talk i will talk about uncertainty
quantification for the ranking program
and if you have any questions during my
talk please feel free to interrupt me
anytime and i will be happy to answer it
this is a joint work with two amazing
collaborators and at the university of
chicago yandi is an instructor in the
department of statistics and child is an
assistant professor there
okay
now i would like to start a talk by
giving you some important applications
for the ranking
in sports and we want to rank we want to
rank the teams according to outcomes or
games among them
another application is in the
recommendation system
when when we watch netflix the website
will recommend movies and tv series to
us and hope we are interested in them
and this is done by some ranking of all
movies based on our personal interest
and the website will recommend the top
ones to us
the third application is so-called
ranked choice voting
so instead of just selecting one
candidate voters can select more than
one and lock them in a sequence and
those votes are then collected to
determine who is who is the winner for
the election
as you can see ranking is everywhere in
our daily life
and it usually involves some powers
comparison data
here is an illustration for the learning
problem from a powers comparison data
we have eight players here and they play
games between each other
it's clear that player 4 shoots the best
one as she wins all the four games
and player 8 he is the weakest one as he
lost all the three games
however for the remaining players and is
not clear on del rank and their
abilities okay so in order to estimate
the ranks and abilities we need a model
the learning problem can be um
modeled by the famous
loose model okay imagine we can we have
n players and we care about their length
and the abilities
in the btl model we assume there is a
true skill parameter vector we call it a
clear star such that for the is player
who rank is c star and i
once we have this vector we
automatically have a
we automatically have a ranking among
all the end players and in this way we
have a longer vector r star so this is a
permutation from 1 to n
for player i could rank is r star i
in the sense that her skill parameter is
equal to this order statistic
let me rephrase it so first we have this
skill parameter and then we can sort the
values from the largest one to the
smallest one and then you can see the
first player now she is in the third
position so her rank is three
and the last and the last player now he
is in the fourth position so his rank is
four so in this way we have this blank
vector
so in the btl model there are two things
we care about
the parameter vector field star and the
rank vector r star
on the bto framework the outcome is
modulated by a bernoulli distribution
okay so for a game between r and j the
probability for i means the game is
proportional to e to the power her skill
and the probability for jib of winning
the game is also proportional to e to
the power and the skill primary skill
parameter of the js trail
so in this way
the probability for i once again is
equals to a logistic transformation of
the difference between these two players
and instead of observing all the paths
we assume we have missing data here
that is we have a comparison graph
with aig being on the newly learned
variable
if aij is wrong it means that we observe
outcomes between i and j
and if that's the case we could assume
there are l outcomes
so the observation can be written as y
idl and it's a new learning variable
with this probability
there is a long list of papers on this
topic it was first started by some
computer scientists and then in the past
10 years it gained more and more
attention from statisticians
especially professor martin willran and
his group here in berkeley
and this late and this topic was also
started by many other researchers
including several ones here in the
audience and this this list is not
incomplete and i apologize if i miss any
literature
despite this long list of papers and
many exciting results
existing literature mostly focuses on
estimation of stellar star especially in
terms of the outer norm and our infinity
norm
it remains unclear how can we do
uncertain quantification for zero star
that is
if we have some estimator to the height
can we calculate the entropy
distribution or theta height
a further question is that if we care
about some individual skill or some
individual rank then can we provide a
confidence interval or some hypothetic
testing procedure for those primary run
parameters
and in today's talk i will provide
provide answers to these questions
another direction is that
instead of
trying to estimate the field star we
want to recover the rank r star
and this is the so-called full ranking
problem and we have
we studied the problem in a different
project
all right
so in the first part of my talk is about
uncertainty kind of uncertainty
quantification for mle which is arguably
the
the most popular method for the btl
model
there are three steps in mle
first we can take an average of all the
outcomes for each pair
and in this way we have the so-called
y-bar-ij
this is a summary statistic which you
can understood you can understand it as
the wing ratio between i and j
and this is the sufficient statistic
according to the bernoulli model
and once we have this y bar idea then we
can write down the negative log
likelihood function as follows
then mle is just a minimizer of this
function
as you can see this is just a logistic
regression problem so this function is
convex
so the computation with mle is easy you
can obtain it by many and convex
optimization methods such as gradient
descent
we have one constraint for this of the
message optimization problem here you
can see we assume
a theta that has an average of zero
this is because there is an
identifiability issue in this btr model
the lack of the function
involves all the differences between and
the scales
so it means that if i increase all the
coordinates of theta by same amount then
the function the value of the function
remains the same
okay so in order to make the mle
identifiable we added this constraint
now let me show you some existing
results for the mle
before that i need to
present a few assumptions
the first assumption is on the ground
truth here star
we have the so-called dynamic range
cover which controls the difference
between the best player and the the
weakest one
so if cover is large it means skills are
diverse
and cover is assumed to be a constant
the second thing is that we assume the
ground truth also has an average of zero
so it's identifiable
in addition to them if we further assume
n times p is bigger than log n
then in the literature and we have the l
two non-bond and our infinity non-bond
here and it is worth mentioning that
this assumption n times p is bigger than
log n is necessary
because we assume that we have missing
data
so and the comparison graph a is a line
graph with an edge probability p
so if n times p is small then the graph
is disconnected
if that's the case then and it's
impossible for us to compare skills from
two players if they have learned two
different sub graphs that are
disconnected from each other
that's why this assumption n times p
bigger than log n is necessary
yeah so here we have a constant here so
it's bigger than a constant
the connectivity is exactly yes
all right but for this result yes it
needs a bigger constant here so that is
again
yes
you remind us what capital l is great
okay so
so if we observe an edge between rng we
assume that l outcomes so l is the
number of games between r and g
right now we have this elbow two
non-bond and our infinitely nonbound
then the question is can we go beyond
all these two bonds especially can we
uncharacterize the distributions
entrance distributions or the mle
for example
if we care about player 1 then can we
see something about the distribution of
this theta 1 head
let me show some a simulation result we
have 100 independent copies of 100
independent data sets generated from a
same syllabus background choose
okay then we can apply the mle
and then we can have 100
independent copies will sit down head
from this simulation you can see
statement one head is centered around
the truth and with a very nice
distribution
in terms of it can be well fitted by a
normal distribution to this blue curve
so from this result we expect mle has
some asymptotic normality
indeed then there are some existing
results on the asymptotic normality of
the mle
when the comparison graph is very dense
so here if p is very big in the sense
that is bigger than n to the power 1 10
then and these two tables show that for
fixed number of coordinates
the mle is asymptotically normal
okay
but there are two things that are not so
satisfying about this result
one more thing is that the assumption on
p is very strong
so previously
for the l two norm and our infinity
number we only need np to be
greater than log n
so there is a big gap between the
assumption here and the assumption here
so the first question is whether we can
have
a weak assumption on p
the second thing is that
this result is asymptotic so can we can
we and can we say something
non-asymptotic
side or no
uh no because everything you know here
we have some covariance matrix
that's here
sure so
depending on n right yeah so in that
result s depend on n
all right now we are ready to present
our results result okay we call it
enormous asymptotically asymptotic
expansion of the mle
okay
so we can obtain explicit formulas for
the difference between the mle and the
ground truth
on the left hand side we have and and we
have the difference for the ice player
so we can show it is equal to this term
we call it the main arrow turn on the
right hand side
up to a one plus epsilon i factor
and
with an eta eye additional error
let's have a look at this main error
term
i mentioned that y bar ig is the win
ratio between i and j
and on the left hand side this is for
the player i so eventually the numerator
is about all the games and she played
and according to the btl model the
expectation of y by ig is equal to the
precise or the difference
then you can see the numerator is
actually about all the linearness in the
outcomes of games she played
for the denominator we can see it
involves some copper prime
which happens to the to be related and
to the variance of y bar ij
so eventually this mean error term is
just an average or a bunch of central
band random variables
and by a standard concentration
inequality we can show the main error
term is in order of one more square root
of npl
anderson couple of questions so just to
recall maybe psi is in this case the
sigmoid function right yes
yeah it's a sigmoid function yeah and so
this seems like an influence function
type expansion
is that what it's doing yeah you can
think about this as like data expansion
all right yeah
the the little lows in this result are
just asymptotic in n or they're
asymptotic in l as well
and everything depends on n l can be one
i see okay yeah you can get a little
loser okay yes
[Music]
all right now let's go back to this
expansion
the left hand side is not exactly equal
to this main error term here we have a
one plus epsilon i factor and the itar
additional error
it turns out we can have some uniform
controls on both parameters
for both terms
for epsilon i we can show with the high
probability the vector has an l infinity
norm upper bound that goes to zero
so the factor is in century 1
for all the coordinates
for the eti we can also show that with
high probability it has an l infinity
norm bound that is equal to a
a small order or one or square root of
npl
and i just mentioned that 1 square root
of npl is all the order mean error term
here
so this additional error is negligible
compared to the main arrowton uniformly
across all the coordinates
so in this way we have a uniform an
expansion of the mle with explicit
formulas for all the coordinates
and only we only need np to be bigger
than 5 equal to 5 bigger than log n to
the power 302
so this is near optimal because the
unnecessary necessary condition is mp
bigger than log n so we only miss a
square root or log n factor here
and there is no assumption needed for on
l the number of games played between two
players and l can be very small as small
as one
yeah
so the expression in your main error
term
looks like it's written for any graph
not just gnp
so i mean do you actually
is have you really proved something for
all graphs and you're applying it to gnp
or do you actually need to assume
that this is gnp
very good question so actually in our
work um
we can show that as long as the graph
starts satisfying some condition then
the results hold and turns out when it's
from a learning graph then it will
satisfy those assumptions you know with
high probability
yeah good question
all right
once we get this result
then we can
have new insights on the l2 nonbond and
our infinite nonbond which i will
explore elaborate in the next few slides
all right so the first implication is on
is on the io2 known bound
and l infinitely nonbound
as i mentioned each coordinate is in
order of 1 square root of npl
so for the l2 norm square bound is
equals to the summation of all the
different of
all the differences squared
and we know each difference squared is
in order of npl and we have n
coordinates here that's why the
autonomous square is in order of 1opl
our result
and also explains why there is a log n
factor in this l infinity norm bound
the l infinite num square is just a
maximum of all the differences
squared and each different square
is in order of npl
and now we need to deal with this
maximum
and in order to deal with this maximum
we can apply a union bond or all the
main error terms here
and by concentration inequalities there
will be a log n term
so all results our result explains why
the l2 norm and l infinitum look look
like this
our result also gives us the asymptotic
numerical
okay and
as i mentioned the main arrowton is just
a summation but just on average or a
bunch of unknown denominator variables
so it's symmetrically normal
and i can move it to the left hand side
then what we have is that the term on
the left hand side converges to a
standard normal distribution
this is just for one
coordinate we can generalize it
and we can show for fixed number of
coordinates
the difference between the mle and the
ground truth of multiplied by some
coefficients
is asymptotically normal
and here you can see our results we only
need
np and to be far very equal to then log
into power 302 is not optimal and this
result is much weaker compared to the
exiting existing result on the
asymptotic numbers
and for those coefficients you can see
they are functions for the ground truth
which is unknown in practice
to make those coefficients data driven
we can replace the ground truth by our
mle
so in this way all the coefficients can
be obtained and from the data
with with this results we can do and we
can do confidence intervals and have
post testings for the skill parameters
let's say we care about two players r
and j
and we and we can provide a one-minute
alpha confidence interval for the
difference between these two skill
parameters
and we can also ask whether they have
the same skill or not
these are all doable because we can show
the difference between the mle and and
the ground choose often multiplied by
those coefficients a and they are
asymptotically but very normal
a more interesting question is to
to infer
some individual rank
let's say
we care about pli and we want to know uh
was his rank r star i
the definition r star i is the order of
his or her skill and among other skill
parameters
we do not have with the ground truth but
we have mle
so if we just want to provide an
uh point estimation then we can you know
sort all the estimated skills and defend
her order
so the point destination is very
straightforward
but what about constructing an allowance
offer confidence confidence interval for
this skill for this rank
if we don't use our new result if we
just use this l infinitely non-bound and
from existing literature let's see what
can we get
and if we only have this result then
from all the estimated scales we can
construct intervals with this length
so in this way we have n intervals
and according to this all infinitely
nonbond we know
the truth and skill parameters they must
be included in this intervals with high
probability
and if two intervals overlap with each
other
then we cannot say anything about the
relative order of these two and two
skill parameters
so if we want to find out in the length
of the earthquake then we need to focus
on the intervals that don't overlap with
either one
so we first count how many intervals
that are structured above the ice
interval and we denote the number as n1
and then we count how many intervals
that are strictly below the item
interval
and we come we denote the number as n2
in this way we have a range it's from n1
plus one to n minus n2
and then we and the true rank must be
included in this interval
this is what we can do if we only use
our infinite number bound you can see
and this result is not wrong but it's
very conservative
and this range it doesn't even depend on
offer
now let me show you what can we do if we
have our new result
okay for the eighth player i can
construct a one minus alpha confidence
interval on focus scale
the length is equals to z one minus half
over two times her standard error
according to the asymptotic numerity
we know her true skill must be included
in this interval with with probability 1
minus alpha
and this length is much shorter compared
to the last interval that
we previously
got from our infinite normal bond
for all the remaining
skills we are going to construct
intervals with a length equal to
the corresponding standard error times a
square root or 2 log n
and according to our an expansion we can
show with the hair probability
all the remaining skill parameters two
skill parameters must be included in
this n minus 1 intervals
with high probability
and one thing i would like to mention is
that for this n minus 1 intervals even
though there is a square root of log n
factor in the length
but their length
much shorter compared to the length
we got here from the our infinity number
bound
this is because
now we can we are able to identify all
the each all the individual standard
errors
that's why it's shorter
then we can apply the same argument we
count how many intervals that are
strictly above the ice interval and the
number is n one prime
and we can denote the number of
intervals that are strictly below the f1
and the number is n2 prime
and then we can show the probability for
her true rank to be included in this
range
and one prime plus one to n minus into
prime is very close to one minus alpha
yeah
sorry this is probably clarification
question so for your asymptotic
normality result when you're looking
across players you only have the
guarantee for a fixed number right yes
but is the reason that doesn't hurt you
here is the others you're sort of just
blowing up by a root to log n factor
like you don't have simultaneously for
everything right so so i'm just trying
to understand uh yes very good question
so pre okay let me go back to the
okay so for our asymptotic numerical
result it only holds for a fixed number
of coordinates so we cannot apply this
result directly
on the intervals of the limiting players
and in order to get this result we can
apply a union bound if we can go back to
the main result
main result you can see the main result
codes for
uniformly for all the coordinates so we
can apply unit bond here and then we can
and get the length
okay so in this way we we have a valid
woman's offer confidence interval for q
rank
okay now let's look at let's go back to
our result we said that the left hand
side is very close to this term then you
may wonder why do we have why we have
this main algorithm
and here is some equation
let me first write down the negative log
likelihood function and we know theta
height is a minimizer of this function
and here i call this
as a global function because you can see
it involves all the parameters
if we only care about state high then we
can write down a local likely function
and here it only involves in games play
the
games related to the ice player
and in order to distinguish theta i from
the remaining coordinates we use this
notation so acidic semicolon and theta
negative i
and as we know the global function is
convex so mle and is coordinate oomle
must be a minimizer for this local
function with theta hex network here
and this local optimization problem is
our starting point
so for theta r hat it's just a solution
to this univariate reduced regression
religious regression is convex but we
know it doesn't have an explicit formula
for the solution
so in order to have some explicit
expression for theta height i
we are going to apply a tail expansion
of the objective function along the
truth
in this way we have this blue curve a
quadratic function
in other words we approximate the
objective function bang bang
quadratic function
and intuitively speaking if these two
functions are very close to each other
then the minimizer of this green curve
should be very close to the minimizer of
this blue curve
and the minimizer of the blue curve has
an expressive formula is equal to theta
r hat at i star minus the first
derivative of the
objectives function divided by the
second derivative of the objective
function
and we can further expand both
numerators and both the numerator and
the denominator
and then you can see in both numera both
the numerator and the denominator
involve the estimated scales for the
remaining players
so intuitively speaking they are very
close to ground shoes
so if we replace them by the ground
truth
then we end up with this main error turn
so this is a just a mutation to explain
why the difference between the estimator
and the ground troops is equal to the
main error term here
right so
that's everything for the mlu
my second part of my talk the second
part of my talk is about uncertainty
quantification for another very popular
method the spectrum method
it turns out the analysis we have for
mle can be carried out to analyze the
spectrum method and we can get something
very similar
the special method is also known as the
rank centrality algorithm
it's very similar to the patreon
algorithm used by google for web search
and the spectrum method is slightly more
complicated than the mle but i will
provide some intuition to explain why it
works
it has three steps
in the first step
we can construct a matrix p as follows
for the off-diagonal angle this is just
a product between aig and y by gi
and then we divided it by some big
number d here
for the diagonal energy this is just
just some value so that we can make sure
each row of p
sums to one
and we can we can choose d to be large
enough such that each entry or this
matrix is a value between 0 and 1.
so in this way this p matrix is a
transition matrix for some markov chain
the second step is to find the station
distribution per head
once we have perhaps we can obtain the
final estimator here tilter
by applying a logarithmic transformation
on each coordinate of pi hat
so if this is your first time seeing
this algorithm you may wonder why it
works
okay so let's take a conditional
expansion conditional
expectation of this p matrix
and then we have formulas for all the
coordinates
it turns out it should lower this
population matrix still sounds too long
so this is again a transition matrix but
for a different markov chain
and we can write down a probability
vector path star as follows such that
each coordinate is proportional to e to
the power the corresponding scale
parameter
and it's easy to verify that this pi
star is the stationary distribution of
this population matrix
and if we want to recover the skill
parameters from
pi star what we can do is just to take a
logarithmic transformation for each
coordinate
this is the intuition why the spectrum
method works
in practice we don't have this
population matrix
but we do have a sample matrix then we
can apply the same argument and to have
the final estimate
in the last step after we apply the
logarithmic transformation
um we will shift all the coordinates so
that and the estimator has an average of
zero
and so in this way and it is also
identifiable
the spectrum method that also exists in
resource especially
related to our bond and our infinite
non-bound
and just like mle we want to go beyond
these two norms to characterize its
entropy distributions
is here is some simulation for the
spectrum method
uh again we have independent dss
generated from the same ground truth
according to the btl model
and then for each um
data set we can apply the spectrum
method so we have independent copies of
theta1 tilde
then you can see and it is centered a
long truth with a very nice distribution
okay
so this is our main result for the
spectrum method
we have expressed the formulas for the
difference between the spectrum method
and the ground issues
and the left hand side is a difference
over the spectral estimator for the
x-coordinate and the magnitude truth and
it is equal to this main arrow term here
multiplied by some one-plus epsilon-i
tilde factor and then with some
additional error is i tilde
and we can also show the main error turn
is in order of one or square root or npl
and for this epsilon filter it's very
small with a very small infinite normal
bond that goes to zero
and also we have our infinite normal
bond on this either tilde and that is so
that eta tilde is negligible compared to
the main arrowton across
uniformly for all the coordinates
in soft the main arrow term here for the
spectrum method is different from the
main arrowton for the mle
respective method in the numerator you
can see we have some weight
and also we have a weight in the
denominator
another difference is that in the
denominator of the spectrum method we
have psi
and the
sigmoid function but in mle in the
denominator we have psi prime the
derivative of the sigmoid function
so these two terms are different from
each other
once we have this expansion then
immediately we can have a symmetric
normality for the spectrum method
so for fixed number of coordinates
the difference between the spectral
estimator and the ground choose after
multiply some by some
coefficients
is asymptotically normal
and also we can replace in the ground
truth
here by the spectral estimator so that
all the coefficients they are data
driven
also our assumption
on p is np is far bigger than log n to
power 302 so this is
also near optimal
all right so i have
i have given you two methods the mle and
the spectrum method those are very
popular but the question is which one is
better
let's first have a comparison on the
asymptotic entries variances for these
two methods
and this is the simulation result that
you have seen in the previous slides
the left one is for the spectrum is for
the mle and the right one is for the
spectrum method
and the data is generated from the same
ground truth
there you can see and on the left hand
side the mle theta 1 head is more
concentrated it has a smaller variance
this result can be verified by our
theoretical and
end results so we said that we have a
sympathetic normality for both mle and
the spectrum method
so it's all about a comparison between
these two coefficients
it turns out a very simple question was
the coefficient for a special method is
always smaller or equal to the
coefficient for the mle
our first conclusion is that
the mle has a smaller entrywise
asymptotic variance than the spectral
method so from this point of view the
mle is better than the spectrum method
we can have a further comparison of
these two methods in terms of ro2
estimation
in the literature it is well known that
both method both methods achieve the
wrong op-out rate
and the wrong appeal rate it turns out
to be optimally for the l2 estimation
so it is known that both methods are
really optimal
now with our new result we can identify
the constances
in these two places
we can show the mle that achieves this
rate 1opl
and with this constant
on the other hand the spectrum method
that achieves the same rate one opl but
with a different constant
one thing i would like to mention that
all our analysis here is sharp
you can see we have equations in both
places
so both constants both constances are
sharp
so if we want to have a comparison
between these two methods it's all about
a comparison between these two constants
and turns out the constant for the mle
is always smaller or equal to equal and
then the constant for the spectrum
method
so from this point of view mle is better
with smaller constant
we can ask a further question
that
is the constant for the mle optimal
and to answer this question we can
establish a local minimax lower bound
for the estimation of theta
and you can see
and it has a lower bond with with with
the same constant as the one in the mle
so our second conclusion is mle is
optimal and in our to estimation with
the right constant
and the spectrum method is sub-optimal
with a worse constant
all right so in the last few slides i'm
going to give you some iteration and for
the main error term of the spectrum
method
okay
by the definition the spectral estimator
is equal to the logarithmic
transformation of the corresponding
coordinate in this
stationary distribution
and we know and the ground truth and the
true parameter is also equal to
logarithm of this population stationary
distribution
so the difference between the spectral
estimator and the ground truth is
eventually very close to a difference
between these two coordinates along the
[Music]
sample stationary distribution and this
the other one is in the population
station distribution
this is so it is all about the
perturbation of the stationary
distribution
for pi hat we know it must satisfy this
equation
and then
from the left hand side we can we can
focus on its r coordinate
according to what we have on the right
hand side it must satisfy this equation
the numerator you can see
it involves all the values um from
for g and not equal to i
and these values and intuitive speaking
must be very close to their population
counterparts so we have this term
and then we can plug in
into our formula for the difference
between the spectral estimator and the
ground truth
and eventually we have and this term
and by simple algebra the numerator can
be simplified and and we we have this
one
so this is what we want
and in the denominator we have y by gi
which interior speaking can be replaced
by its expectation
okay that's invention that's why
eventually we end up with this main
arrowton
so that's the intuition why the
difference between the spectral
estimator and the ground truth is equal
to something like this
all right learning level up
so in today's talk and i give i talked
about i talked about uncertainty
quantification for the btl model
so we provide
uh
expansions for two popular methods the
mle and also the spectrum method
with this result we can do conf we can
do hyper testing or construct confidence
intervals for individual rank or
individual skills
and we can have a detailed comparison
between these two important methods
it turns out mle is better than the
spectrum method
if you are interested in our work you
can look at this paper which is
available on archive
so thank you so much for your attention
and i will be happy for any question
thanks so much anderson questions
thank you for the nice talk so i
remember in your previous work you
showed something like uh the mle is
better than the spectrum method by a
constant two
is that true or
at least you're mentioning maybe in your
previous talk you gave someone
oh
okay so i think and uh it's also we do
have a piece of work and it's about
topically ranking so okay so that is
different yeah we yeah we we also
discussed and we also have a comparison
between these two methods in that
setting and yeah maybe maybe it's over
there so but for those constants so i'm
just curious if you can make those
constant precise if you can give some
uh
yeah and then they are precise but i
mean if you can simplify in some ways so
that we know
it's not only like this is better than
that by
an epsilon
is that possible yes and that's a very
good question so here we have some
genetic forms for those constants so
and if we take if we let the ground
choose to be some specific values say
let's say if we consider all the theta i
star that are equal to each other in
that case of course we can simplify them
it turns out in that case these two
these two constants are the same
okay um
but the general idea is that they're
different and this one is always smaller
than in most cases then this one
okay thank you
other questions
[Music]
cheers thanks so say i don't mind about
all the theta values i just want to work
out say one minus epsilon proportion of
the theta values okay do people work on
this because perhaps you could get like
np bigger than
you don't need the whole graph to be
connected right you just need to have
possibly um like a connected component
taking most of the vertices
yeah it's a good question um yeah i
never thought about that so my guess is
yeah possibly you can do it yeah but
i'm not very sure
cheers
with the questions
so um forgive me because i'm not a
statistician so this might be a stupid
question
so there are two widths that one
might imagine one is the width of the
distribution of mles
when we take different
data sets from the same ground truth and
that's what you
calculated okay um the other is more
like the width of the posterior distribu
or the typical with the posterior
distribution
um you know namely the how broad the
peak in the
likelihood in the log likelihood is
so
intuitively these should be roughly the
same
but i'm just curious whether that's the
case
okay so and so
i so
let me know
in this result we also always assume
there is one ground truth is fixed and
we have a distribution for the spectrum
sata spectrum method but yes you can ask
like if
until star is from some distribution and
then what is like the prostate
distribution for
tutor um
yeah i never thought about that and
i expect that the posterior should be
something similar to what i have here
um
but i think you know
and this is this needs some extra work
to establish
i guess
it's common
sometimes that people want to announce
uncertainty they look at the
end of the long likelihood
but that but that's different than what
you've done
that's a good point i'm sorry your
covariance for your
maximum length of that estimator here is
is just the inverse of the fish
information
this is something different oh
yeah this this covariance
so this covariance is not exactly the
inverse of hexane it's approximation of
the inverse of hazard
what is approximate approximation in the
sense that in the asymptotic limit is
consistent
it's a different
variance so for the inverse of the
hessian if we only take a look at the
diagonal interest then yes we end up
with those coefficients i'm not very
sure about you know the off diagonal
entries maybe um
as you've said maybe you know in in
asymmetric sense that the same
i see okay this statement is saying that
for any fixed k coordinates these
estimates are actually asymptotically
uncorrelated yes i see okay thanks
i thought i thought you might just get
something which is like inverse of the
feature because the derivation
is similar to how do you go from
consistency to asymptotic efficiency
right
which is morally speaking
i thought maybe that's what
should pop up yeah yeah so
um but the problem is that in this case
in this city it's very
hard to analyze the inverse of hessian
okay yeah so that's why we try to solve
the problem from different perspective
and end up with this
quick follow-up to that is that also the
reason why you have fixed number of
coordinates because the full haitian is
difficult to analyze
uh
[Music]
well you can you can see in a minute
well in the main main extension you know
this resource is somewhat you know
related to the inverse or hessian but
for this result we can get this result
but for the expansion we can get things
like that but for the asymptotic numeric
it's hard
so i have a question so
so i think your answer to one of the
previous questions was that your result
can accommodate more than gmp
uh
so so you can accommodate a more general
graph i think
uh i'm not be curious about what kind of
graphs you can accommodate because i
think the l infinity norm kind of bound
relies
very heavily on the random structure so
like what kind of graphs can you
accomplish oh okay um
okay that's a good point so i would say
like one thing one generalization is
that um instead of assuming that we have
the comma t for all edges we can have
different in the pid and but if they are
in the same order i think that should be
fine um
uh
yeah but but we cannot talk about some
arbitrary graph which can be very
different from what we can realize for
random graph so so for example like for
random geometric graph those kind of
things can you can you do something
good question i don't know
yeah so i like your intuition but i
think every time like in the end you
somehow replace this sigma hat also i
see that i had by the ground truth uh
you know when you explain the intuition
and so i guess that's the key part so
how you deal with that exactly
very very good question so
so here i talked about intuition for
main results you can see we have a lot
of approximations some are sharp like
this one the projected approximation but
the last one where we replace the
estimated values but
by our choose this is not technically
this is not right so turns out in our
paper we have some
technique
um uh and that we go along the you know
plugging in the branches here directly
so
this is just inflation it's not rigorous
at all
is that related to this level out
analysis very good question so
i i didn't talk about our proof strategy
because i don't want my talk to be very
technical uh
okay so and but i can comment and a
little bit about our tech our proof so
previously for the for the for this
result especially for the l infinity
norm bound people use this the so-called
luang technique which is very and
delicate it turns out if we need to
get our new results we
live off is not enough and we develop
the so-called liver2 out technique and
in this way we are able to get this
result
okay um
yeah a good question uh
i don't want to go to
go into the details or the technical
part i think we can you know discuss in
offline
um
so
a great talk by the way just um one last
question hopefully
um
so
presumably if if the condition np not i
mean greater than greater than log n to
the three halves is not satisfied this
is a biased estimator
right
is that is that the right way to think
about it that theta hat is biased for
every single theta star
so you mean if this is not satisfied so
it's somewhere between log and log to
the three halves
okay um and then maybe the follow-up
question to that is if it is biased can
you characterize this bias d bias and
and still do something with it okay very
good question so the question is about
this
assumption also turns out you know as i
mentioned we use the so-called
lieutenant for and to get this result
and there we need this assumption and i
think if we
you know it turns out and we think that
we can extend our results instead of
using u2 we can use it using the
so-called liuke
so if that's the case then we can look
at this uh
assumption so in terms eventually if we
can leave out enough you know
coordinates and eventually we can have
something like np is far bigger than log
n to the power one plus you know in
every song this can result
yes so we believe that and estimator is
always on by us
um
other questions
so if there aren't any other questions
uh let's please thank anderson for the
really amazing
[Applause]